which uh speaking of destroying planets
and uh living through the apocalypse i
guess uh we we kind of what a fantastic
segway yeah what a fantastic set we kind
of lived to something like that
yesterday didn't we yeah that was
terrifying we had a very big earthquake
we had two big earthquakes actually
yesterday back to back uh i'm sure the
world news has covered it it's probably
old news by the time you're watching
this but uh
well i mean it was the biggest
earthquake i have lived through so far
i think it was bigger than one than the
one in l.a or at least it felt like it
was bigger than the one in la i think
tokyo was like mag four or five four
four four four point five yeah but i
think it was like magnitude 7.3 yeah
epicenter yeah yeah in fukushima um but
yeah i mean
i thought i'd experienced
like big earthquakes in japan before and
this one like even for people who have
lived here lived in japan for longer
than me said that this was the biggest
one that they've experienced as well
and uh you know it's it's a lot of
people said it's the biggest one they've
experienced since the 2011 earthquake
yeah in uh in fukushima as well yeah
because i think i think it was because
it wasn't just one yeah it was like one
that was pretty big already that caused
another even bigger one yeah literally
two minutes later yeah so it just felt
like one continuously large earthquake
well how was it for you guys
um am i weird i like earthquakes do you
like earthquakes i quite like it
is that bad
like in what sense i feel like a fun
quick time event or something i don't
know
i don't know i don't know why but it
feels kind of fun
is this weird yeah i know this is weird
yeah i don't know actually technically a
natural disaster i know i know because
it's like it causes so many problems
like that's like watching a [ __ ]
like i get it i guess this is what you
don't say that about like tycoons this
is the guy who gave us [ __ ] for looking
at fire like so canister and here he is
being like looking at an earthquake
like
a disaster on like 10 times the
magnitude no more than not like
thousands of times the magnitude of an
exploding can and he's just like oh a
quick time
the bayonetta music starts playing
i obviously protect my um
whatever is valuable in my house but
also it's kind of interesting seeing
what what stays and what falls over i'm
quite quite enjoyable
i understand before you take taking bets
like
i was out and i was kind of like hyped
to think like when i came back i was
like what fell over like nothing fell
over and i was like you were
disappointed
okay
obviously if my tv had fell over i'd be
like
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] but you know when it's
mild ones like obviously because it was
it was a big earthquake but it wasn't
that big in tokyo yeah um
and i like i like those ones but
obviously if it was like eight yeah i'd
be like i'd be another thing entirely
yeah i do not like this one i do not
like this earthquake i mean like one
thing i
do not understand after having lived in
japan and experienced a bunch of
earthquakes now is when do they send out
the earth
when did they start out the earthquake
alarms i do not get like i swear it's
when the epicenter is close enough oh
okay did you get one no no i have never
gotten one since i got my new phone oh
really yeah i've definitely gotten a
bunch but it's only when the epicenter
is close enough to where you live where
it sets it off because it was in
fukushima and miyagi it was like too far
away right but the earthquake was big
enough to the fact that we felt it yeah
yeah because i i hear that i hear the
earthquake alarm and i brace myself and
it's like the pittlies piddliest like
little earthquake i've ever felt like
out of nowhere like yesterday you get
you like the entire [ __ ] house starts
shaking i'm like why didn't i get an
alarm for this i feel like this is like
more prevalent for like the alarm that i
should be bracing myself for
i do if you watch that youtube video
that's like noises that will give you
anxiety if you live in japan or
something yeah yeah and it's like all
the disaster noises yeah you heard the
tsunami one yeah the tsunami was
terrifying it's horrible it's like it's
like like uh like the what's the tower
in pokemon called oh the the [ __ ]
pokemon tower like that that uh no the
one with the dead
uh yeah pokemon pokemon i think no
lavender tower lavender
yeah it's like it's like that level of
creepy yeah the tsunami
oh that's it i [ __ ] hate that it's
horrible yeah that one that one's
horrible dude that one
it sounds like when you get an item in
an rpg it sounds like i just opened a
box in zelda or something
i think it's creepy because like it's
slightly dissonant yeah yeah and it it
feels that
it feels like you're in a room that is
like collapsing and it's designed to do
that and it's like you're dying it's
like it's like you're in a game and you
just like triggered a bad event no no no
no no
have you ever heard like those music
remixes where they take a happy song and
they remix it in like a minor key that's
exactly what it sounds like you talk
about like wrecking
gives me [ __ ] anxiety is the the
earthquake alarms yeah
that one but that one feels dangerous
yeah yeah the tsunami one is creepy
because it doesn't feel like it's it's
like oh my god this is like a
world-ending event yeah
it just sounds like a minor discomfort
yeah
it's like it's like the moles closing
yeah i mean like for my for the
earthquake yesterday for me so it was
actually big enough that it knocked out
the power in uh in my section of tokyo
um
sorry dogs yourself well
it was like the power got outed in a
bunch of i mean i think i think the news
said it was like 2 million homes were
out of power yeah
i might have lost power but i was i was
out so you definitely would have known
if you lost yeah i wasn't there oh okay
you went home okay
i could have gone out yeah my mine was
fine yeah i mean like i actually didn't
even
feel the first one i don't know like
sometimes sometimes people sometimes
people were just like oh there was an
earthquake and i'm like i didn't feel it
was there really an earthquake or did
you just stand up too fast
you know because i that happens to me
sometimes yeah where i think it's an
earthquake happening but it's really
just it's my tripping ball yeah yeah i
just feel like a little lightheaded are
you watching something in dolby atmos i
genuinely i genuinely think there's
always an earthquake happening i'm
watching daily albums
well like the thx starts it's like
yeah so i was actually in my office on
the bottom on the ground floor because i
live in the house and uh sydney was
chilling on the bed um on the third
floor of our house and i just hear
i i just hear sydney going gone gone
gone and uh i'm just like i'm i didn't
know it was an earthquake going on so i
was just like taking my time with it
like let me let me let me let me let me
finish this uh piece of work and i'll
just like casually stroll upstairs and
uh i see sydney like just looking shell
shocked because uh sydney's like really
sensitive to like earthquakes and like
natural disaster kind of thing so she's
just like
did you did you feel that did you feel
that i was like what what what's going
on sydney that was an earthquake god
that was an earthquake and i was like
was there are you sure sydney are you
sure like because i didn't feel i didn't
feel it at all right i didn't feel this
at all
and so i you know i was i was like about
to check my phone to see if you know
every anyone else had posted about it or
anything like that and then just as i go
out
just as i got out my phone it like the
second the second quake hit the second
the bigger one the bigger one and it's
like you know
this one this one it didn't like
immediately start off strong for me it
like shook a little bit it shook a
little bit and so it started shaking i
was like oh that's an earthquake and
sydney was like huh yeah you feel it now
son of a [ __ ] you feel it now you feel
[ __ ] now and then as she finished
that
our lights just like turn off right
actually and there was just an immediate
180 from oh
no no come on come here
all it took was the lights going out but
yeah i mean like
it was actually like pretty surreal for
me
because uh
it was the first time i mean in thailand
we're like [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] used to
power outages we have like plenty of
lights and everything like that um in
here it was just so surreal seeing just
my entire block basically my entire town
just like in complete darkness i think i
posted a video of me just like walking
around outside my house i have never
seen
my street almost in
complete darkness
this
is freaky as hell
which uh because it was the first time i
just seen any side of tokyo just
completely dark yeah emergency lights on
it was like
it was kind of kind of surreal right
like apocalyptic yeah kind of kind of
apocalyptic right um so like because i
was i was what because i thought why not
just take a walk just to see just to see
what the city is take it in yeah just
just to see what the city is like when
we're going through a disaster like this
um
and i think the first time it hit me of
just how surreal this was was i walk out
and you know tokyo was dark but the
point it actually hit me was when i
walked to my main road and i could see
the lawsons had its lights out and i'm
just like holy [ __ ] even the combination
this is the first time i've ever seen
the [ __ ] combination out
like the employees are in there just
like [ __ ] they couldn't even open the
door because like the power
like the automatic door wasn't open i
was like oh this is this is real
i don't know why it was the combini just
because like like i thought no matter
what like a comet could be crashing and
like lawsons would still be like serbia
yeah because like like even when japan
has like the worst typhoon in like the
past 10 years which i think it did like
last year the year before two years ago
the only thing that was open the laws
the combination the combinies are all
over thick and thin yeah so that was
that was the first time yeah that was
that was the first time it was surreal
for me because it was also just seeing
which parts of the grid were still
supported
so actually like because i had a walk
around so like it was some traffic
lights were working and some weren't so
that was that was that was weird traffic
lights weren't working yeah some of the
traffic lights weren't working right but
i think they must have prioritized the
more busier intersections right because
uh all like some of the all the big
intersections were working but some of
the smaller ones
weren't working i always thought the the
uh
road lights and stuff on a separate
thing entirely from the normal people
they might have like a backup system
yeah yeah yeah
the last thing you want is um no no
traffic no traffic lights yeah and there
was actually a traffic accident like
near where that's not surprising at all
yeah i was i think might have been
because of that but like the only thing
that was actually lit was
um was the train stations actually the
train stations had everything working
and the elevators were still working and
everything even though everything else
was like pitch black that wasn't the
only thing that was late gone i was i
was having a great time
in akihabara
i was having a whale of a time i was in
the basement right then some anime song
ball right in there there's a bunch of
japanese men
singing uh macross songs right with a
bunch of
very young looking girls
okay so we went in there and we were
just having a good time
you're like man
i'm [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] lighting this
place on fire man i'm singing now
singing colors
i thought like the base of your voice
was just like so strong that it was
shaking the entire jojo as well so
yeah
i mean everyone in that bar was like oh
they got dolby atmos here
he was like oh there's an earthquake
just now it's like oh i didn't know yeah
then ten seconds later the second one
that was bigger started like shaking and
we were all like yeah
and then yeah but we were in the
basement it was shaking but it wasn't
like that bad like that's why initially
i was quite shocked when i was getting
texts a bunch of text people being like
yeah uh sorry that scared me i was like
ghost ghost earthquake earthquake um
that's why i was quite shocked when i
was getting so many texts and people
being like
oh my god are you okay are you okay yeah
well weirdly enough you don't feel it
when you're underground you feel it when
you're really up higher right yeah i
mean you feel it more at least yeah
you're feeling way more when you're up
high yeah it was all right it was good
because a lot do you get a lot of people
who don't live in japan who don't who
aren't used to earthquakes messaging you
people oh yeah yeah of course oh my gosh
are you okay after after after the round
of like people living in japan tweets
that i saw i started to get like 17
messages from people all over the world
because once it hit the mainstream like
you know international news yeah it's
weird because it's like i get it because
like how could you know the severity of
it but
i think if i'm tweeting about it it's
probably it's probably all that means
i'm okay yeah
all right yeah i mean like i i think
it's worse for like something like chris
right because he was living right next
to it like i can't imagine how strong
the earthquake was for him hit really
hard yeah yeah exactly because i've
never been in an earthquake where a lot
of stuff has literally just like gone on
the floor and started smashing because i
think
i i don't know why i'm oddly calm during
an earthquake and i remember like i like
it you see what i mean it's good i i
don't i don't wouldn't say a lot i
wouldn't say i wouldn't say i like it
right but
it's like i i remember like because i
remember seeing aki's video
that she took
and i related to joey so of course like
because of course me and joey's sharing
the same brainstorm but i remember
relating to joey so hard just seeing aki
just like freaking out going to the bed
and just sitting with like stone cold
face
on the couch which is just like
experiencing the world ending around him
and joey's just
this is fine
it was literally just this is fine face
that's two earthquakes
there's a level six just yeah that was a
little six fukushima
i don't want that the one that got memed
a lot online was uh like afterwards it
started to like really shake right yeah
aki ran to the other side of the house
like to the bed because like uh we
always go to the bedroom because there's
nothing in our bedroom other than our
bed right so there's like we don't have
any worry about things like falling on
us and stuff like that yeah so we go to
the bed
she's like calling out to me i'm like
why the [ __ ] you calling matty you're
the one that left me behind
she like bolts and bolts into the bench
just like joey where are you and i'm
like what do you mean
you left me in the living room
and so there's just this footage of me
just like casually strolling in with my
hand on my head being like oh two
earthquakes
oh [ __ ] sick
and people like just joey just like just
like just as a chad just like walking in
like dad pose like hand on his head just
like i think someone said like why does
he look like a dad that's like waiting
for like an argument
but to be fair in my defense
i i was surprised because i looked way
calmer in that video than i actually was
because i think in
i was like oh [ __ ] this is like really
long also i was worried about my grandma
because she lives up north right so i
was like trying to text her and stuff
but out of context it just looks like me
just [ __ ] standing there just like
waiting for this earthquake to end like
come on
end or end already [ __ ]